a rectangular storage container with an
open top needs to have a volume of 10
cubic meters the length of its base is
twice the width twice the width material
for the base cost 10 dollars per square
meter material for the sides cost six
dollars per square meter find the cost
of the material for the cheapest
container so let's draw this this open
storage container this open rectangular
storage container so it's going to have
an open top so let me draw let me draw
its open top as good as i can
so it's going to have an open top that's
the top of my container
and then let me draw the sides
let me draw
the sides
just like that
so it might look something like that
and then i could draw
and since it's open top i can see
through i can see the inside of the
container as well so the container would
look it would look something something
like that
and so what do they tell us they tell us
that the volume needs to be 10 cubic
meters so let me write that down the
volume needs to be equal to 10
meters cubed the length of its base is
twice the width so the length let's call
well let's call this the width x so the
length is going to be twice that it's
going to be 2x that's what they tell us
right over here they tell us material
for the base costs 10 dollars per square
meter
so the base
so this this area right over here
if it's
if i was transparent i could continue to
draw it down here but this
right over here that material costs 10
dollars per square meter let me label
that
ten dollars ten dollars per square meter
and then they say material for the size
costs six dollars per square meter so
the material over here
material over here costs six dollars per
meter squared
so let's see if we can come up with a
if we can come up with a a value or how
much this this this box would cost to
make as a function of x
but x only gives us the dimensions of
the base we also need a dimension for
height so it'll be a function of x and
height for now so let's write
h as the height right over here so what
is the cost of this container going to
be so the cost
the cost is going to be equal to the
cost of the base well the cost of the
base is going to be 10 dollars
times i'll just write 10.
it's just going to be 10
times the area of the base well what's
the area of the base what's going to be
the width times the length so 10
times x times 2x
that is the cost of base
cost
of
the base and now what's going to be the
cost of the sides
well the diff different sides are going
to have different dimensions you have
this side
over here
and this side over here which have the
same dimension they have they both have
an area of x times h you have x times h
and then our material is six dollars per
square meter so it's six times x times h
would be the cost of
one of these side panels but so for two
of them we have to multiply by two so
plus two times six times h
and then we have these two side panels
we have this side panel
right over here and we have this side
panel
right over here the area of each of them
is going to be 2x times h so it's going
to be 2x
2x times h the cost of the material is
going to be 6. so the cost of one of the
panels is going to be six dollars per
square meters times two x h meter
squared but we have two of these panels
one panel and two panels so we have to
multiply by two
and so we will get so this is right over
here this is the cost of the sides cost
of
the sides and so let's see if we can
simplify this and i'll write it all in a
neutral color so this is going to be
equal to 10. let's see 10 times 2 is 20
x times x is
x squared and you have 2 times 6 times x
h so this is going to be this is going
to be plus 12
x h and then this is going to be 2 times
6 which is 12 times 2 is 24 xh
plus 24
xh so this is going to be equal to 20
x squared
20x squared plus 36 plus 36 xh so this
is going to be my cost but i'm not ready
to optimize it we don't know how to
optimize with respect to two variables
we only know how to optimize with
respect to one variable and maybe i'll
say let's optimize with respect to x
but if we want to optimize with respect
to x we have to express h as a function
of x so how can we do that how can we
express h as a function of x
well we know that the volume has to be
10 cubic meters so we know that x
we know that x
the width times the length times 2x
times the height times h needs to be
equal to 10. or another way of saying
that this tells us
that 2x squared h
2x squared times h needs to be equal to
10. and so if we want h as a function of
x we just divide both sides by 2x
squared and we get h
we get h
is equal to
over 2x squared or we could say that h
is equal to 5 over
5 over x squared and then we can
substitute back right over here h is
equal to 5 over x squared so all of this
business is going to be equal to
20 times x squared plus 36 times x times
5 over x squared
over
x squared
so our cost as a function of x
our cost
of as a function of x is going to be 20
x squared 36 times 5. let's see 30 times
5 is 150 plus another 30 is going to be
180 so it's going to be plus 180 times
let's see x times x to the negative 2
180 x to the
negative
x to the negative 1 power so we finally
have cos as a function of x now we're
ready to optimize
to optimize we just have to figure out
what are the critical points here and
whether those critical points are a
minimum or maximum value so let's see
let's see what we can do so to find a
critical point we take the derivative
figure out where the derivative is
undefined or equal to zero
and those are our candidate critical
points and then
from the critical points we find they
might be minimum or maximum values
so the derivative of c
of our cost with respect to x is going
to be equal to
40 times x
minus
times x to the negative 2 power
now this seems well it's defined for
well it's defined for all x except for x
equaling 0 but x equaling 0 is not
interesting to us as a critical point
because then we're going to have a
degenerate this is going to have no base
at all so we don't want to worry about
that critical point we would have no
volume at all so it would not work out
and actually if x equals zero then our
height is undefined as well so let's see
so this was defined for everything else
for anything other than x equals zero so
let's see when this derivative is equal
to zero as for in our search for
potential critical points so when does
i'll do it over here when does 40
40 x
minus 180
x to the negative 2
equals zero
well we could add the 180x to the
negative 2 to both sides we get 40x
is equal to 180 and i could write it as
180 over
x squared now let's see we could
multiply both sides of this equation by
x squared and we would get 40
x to the third is equal to
is equal to 180 divide both sides by 40
you get x to the third
is equal to 180
over 40 which is the same thing as 18
over 4 which is the same thing as 9 over
2. and so if we want to solve for x we
get that x is equal to
x is equal to the a critical point we
get at a critical point at x is equal to
nine halves to the one third power the
cube root of nine halves so let's see
let's get an approximate value for what
that is
so if we take if we take
nine halves nine divided by two i guess
we could say call that four point five
and we wanna raise it to the one third
power to the one third power we get
1.65 so it's approximately approximately
equal to
1.65 as our critical point now the way
the problem is asked we're only getting
one legitimate critical point here so
that's probably going to be the x at
which we achieve a minimum a minimum
value but let's use our second
derivative test just in case just to
make sure that we're definitely concave
upwards over here in which case that
this will definitely be the x value at
which we achieve a minimum value so the
second derivative
i'll do it right over here the second
derivative of our cost function is just
the derivative of this which is going to
be equal to 40
minus
40 minus
180 times negative 2 which is which is
negative 360. so it's going to be plus
over x to the third
x to the third the derivative of this is
negative 2 times negative 180 which is
positive 360. x to the negative 3 power
which is exactly this right over here
so when x is equal to 1.65 this is going
to be positive this is going to be
positive so let me write this down c
prime prime of 1.65
is definitely greater than zero and so
we're definitely concave upwards when x
is 1.65 concave upwards which means that
our graph is going to look something
like this and so where the derivative
equal to 0 which is right over there we
are at a minimum point we are minimizing
we are minimizing our cost and so if we
go back to the question the only thing
that we have to do now we know the x
value that minimizes our cost we now
have to find the cost of the material
for the cheapest container so we just
have to figure out
we just have to figure out what our cost
is and we already know what our cost is
as a function of x so we just have to
put 1.65 into this equation evaluate the
function at 1.65 so let's do that
we get
our cost is going to be equal to
times 1.65 i should say approximately
equal to because i'm using an
approximation of this original value
1.65
squared
1.65 squared
plus 180 plus 180
i could say divided by 1.65 that's the
same thing as multiplying by 1.65 to the
negative 1. so divided by
1.65
which is equal to
i'll just say
163.5 dollars
so it's approximately so the cost
when let me do this in a new color and
we deserve a drum roll now
all right the cost
when x is 1.65
is approximately equal to
approximately equal to
163.8 five four dollars
so one hundred sixty three point five
four dollars or 163 dollars 54 cents
which is quite an expensive box so this
is this is kind of expensive this is
fairly expensive material here although
it's a fairly large box 1.65 meters in
width it's going to be twice that in and
it's going to be twice that in length
and then you could figure out what its
height is going to be although it's not
going to be too tall 5 divided by 1.65
squared i don't know it'll be roughly a
little under 2 meters tall so it
actually is a quite a large quite a
large box made out of quite expensive
material the minimum cost to make this
box is going to be 163
and 54 cents